[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros y
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con hoy
hablamos con lionel mingo él es
coordinador de campañas de greenpeace
señor mingo gracias por esta
comunicación 14 de las 23 provincias
argentinas han sido afectadas por
incendios y cientos de miles de
hectáreas fueron arrasadas a qué
atribuyen el origen de estos fuegos
bueno es lo que es importante que todos
y todas podamos entender es que esto no
es nuevo los incendios en argentina
tanto en los humedales como en el delta
del paraná como lo que están ocurriendo
ahora en muchas provincias llevan
décadas por supuesto que este año es un
año particular porque debido a la enorme
sequía que hay un enseño que antes era
pequeño ahora se extiende a la magnitud
que estamos viendo pero siempre
sistemáticamente y desde el grupo y lo
venimos denunciando detrás estos
incendios hay emprendimientos ganaderos
hay emprendimientos agropecuarios e
implementos inmobiliarios que son lo que
siempre se benefician con la destrucción
del ecosistema señor mingo y cuáles son
las propuestas desde greenpeace para
enfrentar los incendios
bien sintéticamente hay que entender
otra cuestión en argentina que no hay
ninguna legislación en nuestro país que
proteja los humedales y hay que también
comprender que los humedales abarcan
aproximadamente el 20 por ciento del
territorio del país y más tienes de todo
lo que nuestra protesta un proyecto de
ley que verdaderamente tenga como
intención proteger los humedales tiene
que cumplir con tres ítems
imprescindibles que te paso enumerar
brevemente el primero es que se termine
de una exportadas el inventario de
humedales en el sentido que se sepa
cuántos humedales hay donde están
ubicados cuáles extensión y cuál es su
estado de conservación es deterioro el
segundo ítem es que se tiene que
dictaminar una moratoria en el sentido
que no se permita avanzar más sobre los
humedales hasta tanto no se terminó el
inventario y el trasero y también el más
importante y controversial es que se
tiene que un exportadas incluir las
figuras del delito penal en la ley de
humedales en el sentido que toda persona
que destruya deliberadamente estos
ecosistemas tiene que ir preso las
personas responsables no pueden quedar
impunes por destruir el ecosistema está
importante para la vida del ser humano y
para medio ambiente señor mingo y
considera que las medidas adoptadas por
los gobiernos de las provincias
afectadas son suficientes
no son suficientes pero también hay que
reconocer algo una vez que estos fuegos
de esta magnitud se desatan en un
contexto de sequía es prácticamente
imposible controlarlas en lo que tienen
que hacer los gobiernos tantos
provinciales y principalmente nacionales
no es tratar de apagar un incendio
encendido sino tomar medidas preventivas
para evitar que esto ocurra y una de las
medidas preventivas principales que se
tiene y se debe hacer es como se estaba
comentando la sanción de una ley de
humedales y también endurecer las penas
de la ley de bosques justamente para que
no quede impune esta destrucción de
ecosistemas de los grandes grupos
económicos que están detrás de este
ecocidio ya nos mencionaba señor mingo
que argentina no es el único país con
olas de incendios expertos señalan que
no habrá mejoras sino un cambio de
modelo económico coincide usted es
licenciado en economía es posible un
cambio tan radical
la transformación sea no sea radical es
imperiosa que ocurra porque justamente
el ser humano estamos yendo camino hacia
están hacia nuestra propia
autodestrucción si seguimos así como
bien decir esto no es sólo de argentina
esto no es sólo de este año el año
pasado si bien recordarán los 3 - y
diseños que pone las amazonas
detrás de los incendios de más zonas hay
muchas declaraciones de grandes sectores
agropecuarios que salieron literalmente
a declarar el día del fuego donde
salieron a quemar el amazona justamente
bajo el argumento del desarrollo
económico a través de estos proyectos
ganaderos y agropecuarios esto no
solamente que es inaceptable desde el
punto de vista ambiental es también
aceptable del punto de vista social
porque si se siguen estas vías como bien
decís estamos camino a nuestro auto
propia destrucción
recordemos que el cambio climático es
una realidad pero cambio climático no
viene desde desde con una varita mágica
alguien de afuera el cambio climático lo
estamos fomentando lo estamos sembrando
los seres humanos a través de que
justamente de la destrucción de nuestros
ecosistemas de la destrucción de los
bosques y de la destrucción de los
humedales
muy bien leonel mingo pues muchas
gracias por esta comunicación y su
análisis el es coordinador de campañas
de greenpeace licenciado en economía a
ustedes también muchas gracias por su
compañía los invitamos a que siga con
las noticias al momento en france 24
punto com
[Música]